добрый день это
Стив Я
хочу сказать немного
о это процесс для меня писать по-русски
это это очень
сложно
и как раз я
должен послать моё
писание моя
учительница чтобы она может ээ
исправлять ээ что то что я писал
ээ но тем не менее это это для меня это
э очень интересно опыт
и но когда я говорю не но всё мои ээ
ошибок очевидно но когда она э
отправляет то что
я пишу Но это
ээ
выг
лучше я слушал из Моск я слушал передач
с Алексеем венедиктов и он го он он
говорил сказал что в Ванкувер есть один
другой блогер и я читал
блог Александра очень очень
интересно
ю и я должен сказать что юмор это
это на каждой языка есть свои на каждой
культура есть свои юмор юмор Я говорю
подъезде языка и я и русский Это мой
последний язык это Это я должен сказать
что юмор - это всегда раз но очень люблю
видеть русских и и особенности советских
фильмов и я очень Я видел Бриллиантовая
рука и тоже Ирония судьбы и я должен
сказать что я очень любил Ирония судьбы
э Бриллиантовая рука это это немножко
другое тоже Забавно но
но я
предпочитал Ирония судьбы но
ээ во всяком случае ээ до свидания и
Если у вас есть какой-то
ээ вещи которые вы хотите что я а
ээ что
я говорят но Скажите пожалуйста
на мой б
назви на сре